has net zero an environmental policy
contributed to this energy crisis
it's clear
to us all uh that to keep
uh 1.5 degrees uh in reach
uh we need to consign coal to history
and make clean energy our future
that's official government policy as
laid out by quasi-quatang at the recent
cop 26 summit and in one sense it's been
remarkably effective have a look at this
this is where we got our power from in
the uk these days 27 and a half
gigawatts on average in 2021 and if i
just show you look these are the
component parts of where that power that
electricity comes from and i'll move
them across so we can compare the size
of them have a look look gas the biggest
chunk then wind then nuclear then
biomass and so on it's worth noting a
few things just have a look on the right
hand side how low coal that black bar is
coal that used to be our biggest source
of power but not anymore and that's a
big part of the story of falling
emissions not just in the uk but in many
other countries as well the longer these
bars are the bigger the emissions we're
just comparing general emissions for
different types of fuel sources power
sources and have a look gas the red bit
there that has 44 lower emissions than
coal now of course there's a big gap
between gas and the rest have a look at
the other uh sources in particular uh
looking at wind nuclear and hydro but
don't discount the importance of those
disparities between fossil fuels if
china shifted all of its coal-fired
power stations to gas we'd instantly be
on track to keep global warming below
two degrees c it's a big difference and
in a sense it's more or less what's
happening already have a look at chinese
imports of key fuels here is cold so
that's coal imports into china over the
last few years goes back to 2007 and
here's liquefied natural gas so a form
of gas that you can import and just have
a look at that red line it's overtaken
coal imports that's a massive shift and
that switch in the global energy mix
could be pushing the price higher
everywhere that's what the bank of
england governor said the other day
warning that this dynamic could cause
more price shocks
i think it's very important as we go
forwards with what is obviously a very
long transition
necessarily so
um
to net zero that we understand the
implications of the of the of the
adjustment path here
and we understand the implications for
the demand for conventional energy
sources and how those are switching
because
otherwise um you know we could get more
uh sharks
now it's hard to say how much of an
impact that's had it's probably much
smaller than things like covid or russia
for instance but it's a possible part of
the explanation of why prices are going
up internationally and that matters
especially to countries like the uk
which have quite a lot of wind power why
take a look at this this is our power
mix just the other weekend you see same
kind of shots we had before but for a
single day and have a look at that blue
bar there look at that that's wind wind
accounting for more than half of our
electricity on that day but now look a
few days earlier than that when the wind
wasn't blowing and have a look at how
those bars have changed look went down a
lot about 10 and gas providing the
majority of our power you see the issue
even though we're building out enormous
renewable capacity we still need some
sort of backup for when the wind's not
blowing in the longer run we'll
hopefully have batteries hydrogen or
other sustainable storage but we're not
there yet
we have to develop
cost-effective viable
means of
turning electricity into say hydrogen
storing that hydrogen
in large quantities and then being able
to turn that back into electricity when
the sun isn't shining and the wind isn't
blowing
and for the time being as well as wind
there's gas some days we don't need much
but since the international price is so
high because everyone wants more of it
well that means we end up paying higher
prices so yes environmental policy might
play a part in higher global gas prices
but it's only one of lots of factors but
there's also something you've probably
noticed because it's there in your
monthly energy bill this is the
breakdown of a typical bill as of the
latest off gem numbers that that price
cap coming in and have a look i'm going
to break it down and you can see the
constituent part wholesale costs by far
the biggest part in other words that's
your international gas prices policy
costs over here
there you go now that includes some
environmental contributions but they're
not enormous but they're not trivial
either about eight percent
of bills uh and they do make our bills
higher but here's the thing that is
largely a consequence of the past here's
why renewables used to be much more
expensive than other forms of power this
is one way of looking at it this is
called levelized cost and it's looking
at the energy costs over the entire
lifetime of the plant for things like
gas coal wind and solar this was back in
2009 but just look at what's happened
since then this is 2021 isn't that
extraordinary i'm going to show you just
one more time so back in 2009 here's how
much more expensive wind and solar were
and just look at what's happened since
then they've come down enormously now
cheaper than
gas or coal power stations it's pretty
extraordinary isn't it but we're still
paying off the bill for those expensive
years when those bars were really high
but it's worth noting something else
something important these bars are the
average cost over 30 years so with
fossil fuels that's mostly well that's
fuel it's gas
and coal for the boilers with renewables
the wind and the solar power are free
but most of the cost comes up front so
let's look rather than looking at that
spread over a period of decades let's
look just at those upfront costs so same
kind of thing this is just the capex
costs and just look at how much more
expensive wind and solar are now both of
what i've just shown you there are valid
ways of looking at it but here's why
this version matters here if we were
really serious really serious about net
zero you'd probably expect evidence in
the numbers on total spending we should
be spending quite a lot right now on
wind and solar and less in the future
but is that happening well if we have a
look at global spending on primary power
so this is across the world you can see
it rows and rows up until 2015 and had
it carried on at that rate here's where
it would have gone that dotted line
that's the trend but instead look what's
actually happened
it's essentially
stagnated so for all the talk about
getting to net zero it's not obvious
governments and companies have been
spending quite enough
the government has quite high ambitions
for offshore wind 40 gigawatts by 2030
um but actually we're not yet on track
to get there so we do need to be seeing
greater investment in renewables over
you know particularly over the next five
to ten years
let me show you another chart that shows
you just how much this matters this
one's from the international energy
agents and it shows you just how we're
going to eliminate potentially carbon
emissions if we want to get to net zero
by 2050 that's how you kind of get rid
of it so seven percent comes through
behavioral change that dark blue bit uh
46
that's essentially the technology we
already have so things like wind
turbines deploying solar panels it gets
you further of the way the further we go
there the more of those emissions you've
reduced but 47
look there that red bit the biggest
chunk of this is reliant on technology
that we're still inventing and
developing today that chunk is how we
get to net zero that's how we get there
but again if we are gonna get there we
need to spend a lot more on research and
development to work out how to come up
with that stuff and how are we doing on
that well this chart has the answer i'm
afraid it's a little depressing this is
how much government's been spending uh
investing specifically in energy r d so
working out that tech and as you can see
far from being at record highs it was
back at highs in the post-1970s oil
crisis peak is actually considerably
lower now than it was back then uh 0.004
of gdp being spent by governments on
trying to work out the tech that's going
to get us there you see
put it all together it's not quite the
story you might have expected is net
zero responsible for the current energy
crisis well maybe a bit it's pushing up
global demand for gas lifting our bills
a bit
but the real problem is that while our
politicians have begun to outlaw fossil
fuels it's not obvious they're spending
the necessary amount on green
technologies which means a potential
shortage of supply
long term in other words the real energy
crisis might not be this one but the one
that's coming up in the next few years